good evening and welcome everyone to the
review committee
of september the 7th 2021
before we go into the meeting i have to
make the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the whole entrance doors
turn right walk straight past the
canteen through the external doors on
the right and out to the car park which
is our assembly point
please do not delay your evacuate
evacuation to collect your belongings
please do not return to this building
until you're given permission to do so
by council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off your mobiles
or turn them to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as the microphones
are needed for the hearing loop and for
the audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
for and then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by the officers
agenda item 1
apologies for absence apologies have
been received from councillor laurene
shaw are there any other apologies
okay thank you
there are no substitute members
attending this evening
gender item three non-members attending
we have councillor cheryl rowe
councillor simon wooten councillor dave
sparing councillor julie gooding and
councillor ian ward
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 6th of july
2021 are these minutes agreed members
thank you those agree
agenda item five is to receive
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
thank you chairman um non-pure pecuniary
interest by being a member and chairman
of the carbon neutral working group
thank you chairman
thank you council mrs mcpherson
we move on to
agenda item six which is a report uh on
the parks for nature initiative which
went to the
executive
um marcus hot and the assistant director
for place and environment encounters
dave sparring the portfolio holder for
environment and place are in attendance
for this item
um
i called
i spoke with a number of members and the
reason why this was called in um
were that um
there were a number of areas that
members had approached me and had
concerns about um the first was about
rewilding and the affordability of seeds
and the cost of management
[Music]
rewilding isn't just about not mowing
the grass so there are other elements
which i'm sure
the ad and portfolio holder will talk
about
also many members were concerned within
their walls and that the rewilding
although is a good idea and this would
lead to a loss of amenity space
for community and cultural events across
the district and these these spaces are
a premium um and the third reason was
that consultation
with the users of the space the
stakeholders who actually used the space
and
world members was perhaps um not quite
to the standard that we would expect so
that though those were the um were the
reasons for the calling so um what i'd
like to do is
ask um portfolio holder if
he's got any observations on that please
thank you chairman
um
yes we we've initiated this as part of
the council's policy towards carbon
neutrality
by 2030
this is the first step in a very long
process
we fully understand that and we fully
accept it
we had to start somewhere
and we have made an initial start
there's more to
this whole process as as mr hoffman will
explain regarding resources and how we
administer our grounds maintenance in
future
rather than just rewilding we are aware
of the limitations that we have
financially and by the need for wild
flowers etc etc i'm sure mr hutton can
go into the costings of this and the uh
total labor commitment that is necessary
it's not just oh we'll throw some wild
seed down and they'll grow automatically
we also know that in this area there is
a huge problem because of the very
nature of the soil with lo with
wildflower growing um
that's a a simple reality
we appreciate that
this is a very tentative step
forward but we have made it very clear
from step one this is the first step we
are quite happy to talk to members of
the public
but obviously to try and talk to 400 of
them isn't going to be easy because
they'll all have their own
interpretations of what should be done
what shouldn't be done but by and large
we feel that there is enough space in a
number of our open spaces
that we could
allow
meadow land to regrow
we could in some areas
plant whips as again part of the carbon
neutrality but we do believe that there
is still sufficient ground for
residents to
utilize either play area or just
straightforward recreation area this is
a flexible scenario we have no problem
we made it very clear from day one this
is an ongoing conversation and if we
find that we've got it wrong in the
first place then we will adjust it
we're not concreting anything over
um
the last point sorry chairman was
oh about uh
consultation with
as far as i'm aware
an invitation went out to all
councillors
as to if they were available
to come to meet with myself and adam
aldridge on site visits
a number of board councillors did come
along
um i think the only occasion that
nobody turned up was when we were
visiting two sites in raleigh
but otherwise i can look around here and
see a number of faces who did turn up
for various meetings in various
locations across the district whether it
be great waycrin
or hockley or hawkwell ashington
uh members of the of the council were
invited and did attend jim perhaps
marcus would like to elaborate on some
of the other aspects now chairman
um thank you um
if if i may i'll just um read out from
the minutes
of the uh executive um just just i think
because it emphasizes what council
sparring has said um uh so if you
forgive me for reading um direct the
leaders stressed that there was a
commitment to community need when there
might be conflicts when community and
leisure needs conflicted with the
projects then the council will be
flexible to ensure that compromise is
found and saw that such needs are also
accommodated
the portfolio holder confirmed this to
be the case and adding that the grounds
maintenance service being delivered
in-house from december 2021 would give
the council more flexibility so i think
um
you know in terms of those quite clearly
that you've got something here that's
recorded formally
from the leader that's backed up by the
portfolio hold that there will be a
flexible approach um
the
there has to be a starting point in
terms of calculating the level of
resources required for the new contracts
the devil in the detail is
a site-by-site basis we've obviously
gone through some consultation i
accept that
until the grass is growing on the ground
will it be a reality for people at times
and in many ways
um it is not hard to cut the grass in a
different pattern or to cut a bit more
to leave a little bit less off
particularly with
what is
a um
an in-house service and that was one of
the things that um
council sparring and i
discussed at length was the need for
this to be an in-house service so the
flexibility was there to allow for the
responsiveness to the various concerns
that we raise as we go along but you
know in truthfulness when you're doing
something across this
um across a district at this this level
then there is a consultation that can
establish the
the concept that it's a good idea but we
acknowledge i think both of us
acknowledge that in terms of actual
sites that until you get out there and
start cutting the grass and start
playing the trees will it become an
obvious reality so it's very schematic
it's about
quantities that i can then use to sort
of basically calculate the level of
resources required because there will be
flexibility as we go along
um in terms of resourcing
um
i think the three areas i guess of
resourcing that you'd look out for this
the first is tree planting
and there are many many sources of
funding for tree planting the three that
come to mind are the forest commission
the woodlands trust and the essex forest
initiative are our three the essex
forest initiative are
actively uh looking for local
authorities to deliver their targets and
and so therefore it's it's a current
resource that's available and one that
we are in conversation with
in terms of that obviously we are
leaving the grass to grow longer and
then have to cut and collect that there
is a capital allocation 54 000 towards
equipment to do so
and and the last i did put wildflowers i
think that was touched upon
it will be something we look at at a
later date and that's from my own
experiences i i do like wildflower
meadows but i also know that they are um
a very unforgiving thing to establish
and so certainly i would emphasize that
this early stage to go sowing wildflower
seed into the meadows will not deliver
the results you hoped to achieve so what
you want to do initially is set out the
areas of long grass that you wish to
achieve and then bring in a regime after
that but you cannot do it all in one go
you know i've tried before and the
success rate is very low so for example
um to do so
uh if you if you wanted to go down that
route you'd be talking about
spraying off the existing grass or
perhaps even removing the topsoil to sow
wildflower seed now that is a very
drastic change to something where we
said we want flexibility initially
so you know it's about what looks right
first there is still a huge benefit in
terms of carbon um um reduction in terms
of leaving grass long in terms of the
the sink that it calls carbon sink that
it represents in that you leave them
standing long grass and in terms of
things like overweight wintering
invertebrates it's a very good habitat
as well so it's not always just about
wild flowers it's a great resource to
have wild flowers but
some of these sites and again i think
this is where we have to um see how each
site goes
some sites will lend themselves to
wildflowers better than others
some will just not yield good
wildflowers and it may be that we decide
that those are the ones we want to
constrain giving a close of sword or
cutting
short grass for a longer period but it's
it's not something i can just literally
draw on that and say that you'll get
wildflowers here it's you know it's a
um a two or three year
if you like teasing out of that over the
site to see where we best
so that's at this stage why the
resources before but in terms of
resourcing again um i'm confident we'll
be able to access various funds that are
available for sort of conservation
projects as we consider the way we've
done for play schemes
thank you mr hotten do members have any
questions or observations
council and mrs mason
so
thank you
thank you mr chairman
concern is raised about both
inaccuracies and assumptions in the
report and the failure to consider all
aspects of park use
whilst i am wholly supportive both of
rewilding
properly done and managed and tree
planting
and meadowland this report is not
considered the demerits of taking our
much valued open spaces and altering
their use
nor apparently considered the impact on
residents that use these spaces
the report at 4.5 states that the plans
have been developed in conjunction with
respective world members for each open
space
whilst i cannot speak for other areas
this is untrue of my own world
i was invited to a meeting
told what was being done
without any map or visual representation
as the device the officer was using was
not visible in the sun and yes it was
one of those rare sunny days
being told is not a flexible approach
a map was promised but has failed to
materialize and the layout on the
proposal is different to that verbally
expressed
i was also advised that there was no
budget for rewilding
yet
meadowland and conservation area is
large shown on a large proportion of the
areas
rewilding does not mean a lack of
maintenance indeed properly carried out
it is very labor intensive
conservation meadow does not mean let
the weeds dominate and leave uncut
this is just lack of maintenance
sadly this appears to be more of a
cost-cutting exercise rather than a
positive attempt to improve our open
spaces
the report states that the consultation
took place with 330 responses
over 29 sites
this equals 11 responses per site
but of course those respondees
may have been commenting generally
would not necessarily cite
users and rdc may not have reached users
of every site
indeed it is more likely
that they have not
to press ahead with such a drastic
change in our open spaces without
considering the users of these spaces is
unacceptable
i have spoken with users of clemence
hall recreation ground
not one was aware of the proposed
changes
or the consultation
they were unanimously opposed to the
changes
when we are building more and more
properties with smaller garden areas the
large open spaces that we have are
vitally important to the well-being of
our residents
using clements hall recreation ground
as an example the one thing that was
most valuable to residents was the sense
of space it provides and the various
uses it can accommodate
from putting exercising dog walking
pretend camping
football cricket kite flying and other
ball games most of these would be
rendered and sustainable in a smaller
area or at best create conflict between
users
surely we need to consider our users
mental and physical wellbeing above all
else
why of the park users
not being consulted
why has true what rewilding not been
considered
why have the other uses of our openness
spaces
not being considered
well i want to ensure that the intention
behind
these plans is good the failure to
properly consider all aspects calls for
a drastic rethink
i would like to see these proposals
referred back to the various locations
and a representative consultation
undertaken with both world counsellors
and residents of each site consulted not
just informed
and each site treated independently on a
site-by-site basis
the user is currently enjoyed should be
considered and evaluated before any
expensive and unreversible
alteration is made this should be done
by small working groups and i have some
photographs here just to indicate
the current usage of the open spaces
where
rochester council wishes to put trees
these um
these
there's no children in them because of
uh safeguarding i asked for the children
except for the one whose parents gave
permission to be taken out
but these were child-minding they were
they were able to use the space because
it was a large space and no one imposed
on them or came near the children if the
space was reduced we could go back
perhaps to the other ones if the space
was reduced
they said they wouldn't be able to use
that the field for that facility and
this is just one of the areas we can go
into the next slide please
again it shows the amount of land that
just one group people use which they
wouldn't be able to do in their own back
garden next slide please
this shows
unfortunately the current status of
some of the land at clements hall
recreation next slide please
and again
this this shows that at present we are
not maintaining our open spaces
particularly well it doesn't show up
particularly in that photograph but
actually you can't walk down that
footpath because of the overhanging
branches
it's it's obscured and that's on the
entrance to clemence hall next slide
please
again
uncut
and the clemence hall was in such a
state for so long that i can assure you
residents couldn't use it i walked
across it on a dry day and i had to go
home to change because the grass was so
low i got my my shoes were soaked
through so for some period of this
summer it has been unusable and that is
not acceptable with one of our major
open spaces next slide please
again it just shows the
quality of the maintenance that we have
at the moment next slide please
and again yes but and it's it's
unfortunate i don't really want to
criticize i realize it's been a very
difficult year for our
uh groundsmen but the the cutting of the
grass and the rendering of this um
area unusual there was not a one single
bench in clements hall
that our residents can use
and we need to perhaps improve what we
have and certainly i'm all for
the suggestion of improving it with
planting and
some meadowland but i do think we ought
to also consider all users
and i'd like that recommendation that
this is referred back to be considered
thank you
thank you council mason mr cotton and uh
would you like to uh comply please yeah
i'm i think working backwards
if i may um
obviously the maintenance of the park is
uh a matter of debate but but it
this isn't parks and nature
that this is a product of this is just a
product of the existing maintenance so
in terms of of
bringing up tonight i i don't see that
the value in what you're implying so so
for example these areas would i think
something could be cut short some of
these would be left long but it's hard
to
um draw inference on that because you've
shown these as formal areas well then
that's what i'm saying so so although
you're saying you're complaining and
being informal here it's not to do with
parks and nature to do the existing
grounds maintenance contracts okay if i
can just come back on that one of the
other
areas of concern is that this particular
photograph here is demonstrating it's in
the leisure area and what this report
hasn't considered is the crossover
between the future leisure contract uh
my view is that this is this area which
is shown is next to the car parks and i
would have thought this area should be
maintained
by whoever's got our leisure contract
and that is something that
needs to be considered the whole thing
needs to be reconsidered i think
on a case-by-case basis it's not really
a debate i don't think here
because i think it's so complex and i
think council sparing is quite right it
is a long-term situation
but it needs to go back to be looked at
and if i can find these issues on just
one area then i suspect other counselors
have similar issues and some may not
have any on their walls and those can go
ahead and the others cannot
need to be tweaked but to just
rubber stamp the report as it stands i
think would be a mistake
but
if i if i may um again the executive
minutes
you know um are fairly explicit and that
that there will be flexibility
so that there's a starting point in
terms of resource but in terms of
exactly where grass would become where
we left short and long you know
it has to be by site by site and again
the consultation was undertaken was more
about the principle um it's very hard to
do a district-wide consultation
absolutely correct in terms of
individual sites it's it's to establish
the principle of of doing so which i
think we all recognize is a good thing
and i said that the devil will be in the
detail um
and as we as we play with the sites i
think it is almost a way to describe it
then of course if certain areas have to
be cut and certain areas can be left
long then there will be that flexibility
we will listen and we'll listen to
members unfortunately that wasn't my
experience when i was told what was
being done but yeah i accept that that
might be the intention but i would like
i would like to recommend that this
goes back and and each site is looked at
on a site-by-site basis with
consultation
with the park users
critically
thank you mr chairman
thank you and just there would one very
specific point that was raised by
council mrs mason um
which was to say this was a
cross-cutting exercise i don't believe
that you've said that
the saving in not cutting some of this
land this intermission information i i
don't know why we actually going down
this road of trying to improve the
carbon neutrality scenario because it
seems that the whole of clements hall is
not open for any anything other than
what it currently is i'm sorry perhaps i
misunderstood that but
the whole area is used full time by all
the residents so if that's the case
i'm no doubt most most of the
councillors could say the same case for
everything so
the whole scenario would never get off
the ground the reality of
what it would cost to cut the whole
field in instead of three quarters is
negligible the fact that i have
marcus and his crew have to take a very
heavy unit to carry all the
mowers etcetera down there probably uses
more of a diesel we're going to go down
there with the mowers
all we're talking about is instead of
cutting for
20 minutes we're cutting for 15.
in the whole scheme of things the money
involved is negligible in the whole
budget that we have to deal with each
year
so to say that is a cost cutting
exercise is just a a mis misnomer i'm
sorry it doesn't exist that is not the
principle be behind what we are trying
to do we are trying to support the
council's policy of moving along to a
carbon neutral scenario by 2030 and
in conjunction with what we've got to do
with the financial resources and our
labor
forces this is
a joint approach to what we believe
would be a satisfactory outcome for
all the residents of this district if we
didn't think it was worthwhile i'm sure
that marcus myself and the executive
wouldn't have supported it
but you know that they have
we've put our case together the
executive have listened to the arguments
and have signed off on it
i don't think there's really very much
more i can say chairman thank you
council
councillor newport please
thank you chairman
um so i i've listened uh carefully to
what um
marcus and councillor sparring have said
about this
initiative
so i had to prepare something so i'm
going to try and adjust it because i
don't want to go over old ground um
with this but
i miss i assume that the
so i'll just lead with a question
because i assume that the reason the
report
was linked with the grounds maintenance
contract
and the grounds maintenance contract
was on the agenda has not been discussed
so i'm not really going to discuss that
but i just wanted to raise a point out
that where there is a saving of a
hundred thousand and i wondered if that
money was going to be reinvested
in the parks and green spaces
into this initiative
so that i'll leave that question there
um
so
i note that in the report that they the
council assumes that the options
available would improve the open spaces
but i think that's rather subjective
depending on who you are
okay so
can improve things for wildlife
or it can reduce the immunity for
residents
there's a fine balance to achieve and i
think we'd all agree with that
so i think this goes back to the point
of the consultation
and i think this is quite a bug bet
because
as a ward councillor and my fellow ward
councillors we've received
over a dozen emails and
messages about it and particularly in
one area behind rayleigh leisure center
as a site
um
where
that space has been not maintained so
if we were to leave that grow long in
the future you know they've already
noticed the loss of amenity in that
space
i wanted to put a point across
on that particular space where parents
who used to have a kick about with their
kids
can no longer do that
and
other residents have complained about
the doc fouling that's hidden in the
long grass
they're all relevant points and ones
that should be considered and come out
of consultation really with with our
residents
the consultation process
as the paragraph 4.5 and page 6.4
that we were all invited we were all
invited and we all gave dates and times
when we could go
and on the day which came through for me
i couldn't go because of my work
commitments one of my fellow wall
councillors also
is in full-time employment he couldn't
go it was pouring down with rain and our
other water council is elderly and
suffered ill health
so and counselor sparing is aware
because it was pouring down with rain on
that day no i'm failing it you were out
in it yes but we don't all have the same
good health as you and i can and i think
we can accept that some counselors maybe
didn't want to go out in the rain
so but we weren't offered another day
and i think that's a bit of a
you know we could have been offered
another date to go out i would have been
keen to meet count councillor sparring
and adam
to talk about it and i know that
councillor stanley would have been there
like a shot okay
so i think we can all accept that
um
other members i know had to prompt
officers to arrange a visit
the
other thing that i note from the quest
public questionnaire
was i didn't see evidence of a
consultation with the groups or clubs
that use those spaces
now i've had
um groups and clubs contact me football
groups where they do training didn't
know about it um they have suffered a
loss of a training ground
what i don't see in the report and i
know that we you've spoken about the
detail um moving forward but one thing
that i don't see
is
about the monitoring and how the success
of failure of the scheme will be
monitored
now
in my day we'd be out with a quadrant
um looking at the species counting
species you know i know that we're going
into technical aspects though but how
will it be monitored how will the
performance how well will that you know
how is that going to be reported are you
going to
come back and say to us you know we've
got 10 new species there i don't know
but that's another question
that i have
one of the other questions that i have
is
wouldn't it be pertinent to make the
public aware of what effect this will
have on species and habitats
and also the carbon sequestration
expectation of the scheme
what is the council aiming to achieve
what are the targets what is the effect
that this scheme will have on our
district
my
my suggestion to this committee
would be
following on from what councilor mason
has said
that we should have a working party that
is a biodiversity and environmental
awareness party which is formed
and comprises of officers councillors
and local and regional wildlife
organizations such as
english nature essex wildlife trust and
other specialist wildlife groups
this working party should work with
the volunteers and friends groups also
and engage with local schools and other
clubs such as cubs and scouts
now i haven't just i haven't just dreamt
this up
i've looked at what other councils have
done
so
there's a council close to us
that have done these sorts of schemes
south end
in belfast and we should look at what
they've done and what lessons they've
already learned
you know so we're not repeating
or creating ourselves problems but that
would be my
recommendation thank you
um so
in
is that
yeah in response to the recommendation i
mean i mean yes i mean it's um i thought
you're actually going to say baslin then
because it's what i used to do as a job
there um
very much this sort of thing working
partnership with um sort of a wildlife
trust and actually england and the like
and we're the wildlife and countryside
forum
where we discussed and how we could
further biodiversity sort of gain for
the district so i guess you're right it
can be done um
i would say not with the current
resource i have available it's an
aspiration so but in terms of the new
structure um i think we talked about
this community ranger role then that is
the role that we'd expect to anticipate
doing that kind of work so they'll be
doing community work and looking to work
with partners external partners and in
the biodiversity and sort of interests
such as wildlife trust so it would it
would have called with that
recommendation
and my other question
so you've asked about in terms of how
will it be monitored
i mean
we have in the main spoken about in
terms of achieve helping achieve carbon
2030 sort of targets so it will be in
terms of output in in terms of acreage
of
and uh in terms of trees planted and
then we'll work out what what that is in
terms of carbon um sort of sink in as we
go along so
you know it's
not going to be an exact science that
there is no exact science and i think
it's just recognized that to to plant
more trees and to allow areas of natural
standing hard grasslands uh is
beneficial to to offset in carbon
um the carbon footprint of the council
and so we'll be able to come up with
some sort of estimates of that as we go
along
but in terms of monitoring for specific
species
there hasn't been a thrust of argument
that the the um
that that's what we're going for there
there will be some beneficial
i suspect gain
but i wasn't intending to monitor per se
on those species
cancer mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman um i haven't actually
produced any um
written statement
i must admit i i don't know about other
members if
i have a question
on anything to do with
this or other items i do tend to always
ask the officers or the portfolio holder
who often come back and
quite quickly and answer those questions
but just to give you some background
um
the parts for nature came before the
carbon neutral working group
a group open to any member here i would
encourage you if you would like to join
us you will be more than welcome
at the very start
there has to be something
that we have to remember one thing that
is set in stone we have to reduce our
carbon footprint
when this first came to the working
group i asked when looking at the
original plans is this open to change
i was assured it was
site visits were organized
i was lucky enough to be able to make
hours
um
i
we were given a couple of dates to
choose from hopefully other people were
too
at the site
i asked when we're actually seeing it
out there in the park is this open to be
changed
if need be
when more groups are involved in it
when people start to see what's
happening
yes it is
this as the officer has already read out
was reaffirmed at the minutes of the
executive meeting
this is the start of our journey
towards making a difference to our
carbon footprint the start
i am a user of the parks
i also volunteer putting on many
activities at many of the sites so i do
know that people will still want to be
able to use them and use them well
and as council newport wisely said
this has to be a fine balance to achieve
this morning we had another carbon
neutral working group
and those present
will be able to vote vouch that we spoke
on this project then
we were talking about
other councils how we can engage with
them
as council newport just mentioned the
friends of cherry orchard park were
actually mentioned
so those groups will be invited to be
part of that and hopefully also feed
into the carbon mutual working group
thank you very much chairman
thank you councilman person counselor
mrs
and chair
and joe's actually said quite a few
things that i was going to comment on
from my understanding from the onset the
portfolio holders made it very clear
that this is a work in progress that
things can change as we go along and
nothing's set in stone
and regarding the consultation um i
believe i was one of the first members
that went out on the consultation
and i was given various options of which
time suited that i could attend
and
i'm just wondering who christine mason
who this officer
that christine could get a word in
oh sorry what was it
not offered
told to what to do i found it
sorry i'll correct that
my point is
miss mason is that the officer that
and to you sorry
my point is that the officer that took
us out
went out of his way to discuss options
listen to our opinions come up with
suggestions at no point did he tell me
as an officer as a counselor what was
going to happen it was all up for for
debate
and all the way through this process
when i've spoken to
other officers and the portfolio holder
i've been constantly told this is not
set in stone things can change and
with regard in the middle grass my
understanding is is that if it doesn't
work we can take that back to grass so
my understanding is is that we're trying
to make carbon neutral the officers are
doing a grand job at trying to work
towards that and i feel that we need to
support this obviously balancing if with
the needs of the residents
but on my visit i actually spoke to
residents
at the sites that i visited and asked
their opinions and most of them welcomed
the idea of meadow grass of
changing the use slightly and i didn't
receive any objections and they all had
an opportunity to put their voice
through to me
thank you
thank you councillor foster please
cancel
thank you very much
thank you chairman um i read the report
and i joined with councillor mrs shaw in
the walk with the officer
in the
areas in
our ward
i recognize this as a first step
and
after initial consultation of course and
i am reassured
that members views including some
previously expressed
will be incorporated as work progresses
by
recognizing this is as i said the first
step
as it goes forward i support the view of
expanding
public involvement
or
increasing involvement in the work group
i'm happy to join with the work group if
it helps
and
look forward to maybe being able to
contribute thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson
i'm gonna have to touch it
thank you
thank you chair
i wasn't one of the members that called
this in at all and i can assure every
member here that i come in here this
evening with a completely open mind
um
i
do fully support the concept behind this
i have to say
and i think it's um it's right
to do everything we can to work towards
carbon neutrality and i think it's right
to do everything we can as well to
increase
our wildlife options across the district
there's only one aspect of this that
gives me concern
um which i could ask for a bit of
reassurance on maybe and it's
a lot of members are talking about
member consultation
um i know it has been mentioned about
public consultation but the last couple
of members have spoken haven't mentioned
public consultation and that's what
concerns me
330 people
across a district of 85 000
now
i know we don't tend to get a lot of
respondents to our surveys i think the
cctv working group we got the most it's
about 600 650 something like that
um
which is twice as many as this however
i i think that's not down to any lack of
effort on the part of those with this
particular
survey i think it's down to our comms
generally as a council i think our
consultation methods are particularly
poor it's my observation so when you get
330 responders i don't
tend to miss many
surveys that come out but i did miss
this if i'm honest otherwise i would
have circulated to my
my wall council doesn't mean to say that
i wasn't sent it but i did miss it
and it does concern me
that we are
looking at reshaping the areas that are
used by members of the public
when really they've not been spoken to
we're making the decision on their
behalf for the right reasons i get
but we're making decisions on their
behalf that's not what we should be
doing really we should be consulting
with them
so my question really is
acknowledging the fact that you've said
this as a first step
what's the next step and
what does the public consultation moving
forward look like thank you
so i mean so i said it's
consultation site by site can be quite
challenging um you know and um having
undertaken site management on sites
before where i've um you know in my
younger years i've missed written
management plans and then put them out
for consultation and i think and the
like
the response can be quite low
and from experience quite often it's
only
once something is happening on site do
you tend to get the response uh that you
require um but it but in many ways had
the the maps that were created were
schematic maps almost block maps just
for us to work out quantities what we're
working with in terms of resourcing um
what we require to do is basically
develop better
um
professionally produced maps that will
go up on it on each site to say this is
what we're doing these are the areas
we're intending to leave as long grass
with signs up saying this is why
um now
in many ways we're encouraged response
to that
but i i don't
trying to encourage a
individual consultation for each site i
suspect will be um a law diminishing
returns in terms of efforts
um
and i think in many ways that you'll
have people's attention when they
actually visit the site and say what is
this that's going on this is why we're
saying about the flexibility because the
best will in the world um we'll have
some people say i don't want to see
anything change
and then when it's actually on the
ground and you have areas of long grass
actually that doesn't look too bad at
all it's you know
there's an aesthetic level here that's
quite hard to translate and commute and
communicate until it's actually there in
front of you so i i i the next stage is
to develop decent maps that look
credible um but but in doing so i what
we did want to speak to members again
because we we've heard what's been said
so you know
in terms of actually shaping us because
at the moment that they are very blocky
and i certainly wouldn't want those to
be seen um as a final final solution so
we want to produce something that's
actually can be put up at each site to
say
this is the parks and nature scheme it's
badged up this is what proposing for
each site and you start to put up
individual sites so this area has been
left as the conservation
and so people can see which areas are
going to be left that kind of thing but
it's very hard to because it's very hard
in my experience to
translate that particularly well until
it's actually happening on the site and
that's just my own personal experience
of these things in the past with
managing plans and the like that you can
you can consult to the nth degree
and and you still do not get the
response you expect until you actually
are carrying out and and that's hence
why the flexibility is there and that's
why i think event size all the way
through
we will be flexible to people's concerns
and needs as they develop
check mike just come back if you don't
mind thank you thanks mr holden i just
do do you think that 330 respondents is
a meaningful
consultation and is it something you can
form your um your plans moving forward
on and if not what can we do better
because
i i in my view i don't think it's
meaningful i think it's it's it's an
awful response and really we should we
should be looking at that as how can we
do that better so so so i mean our
answer but just really with development
what would you say is a a decent number
so we can hold you to that for the
future of consultations
well that's not
so it's a lot more than 330.
so but that's not in itself so you
understand that the
consultations are a little bit of a um
so from my point of view if the
consultation had come back and said it's
50 50
um
in terms of responses then you'd say as
a litmus test as a temperature test this
clearly is something that needs
exploring forever as a policy with a 92
response to the rate that was favorable
although it's a very small
um sample statistically it's still you
know 300 still statistically um valid
then then you'd say that as a principle
um that it it would appear to be a good
idea and i think you know looking across
the members again we've all nodded to
say well actually we think this is a
good idea we support the principle and
the question there was very much about
the principle across the districts
we didn't
you know to try to do a
a sort of questionnaire that on
individual sites just just just wouldn't
elicit the response you require to to do
something meaningful but whether 300 i
would say that is comparable to other
two other districts have done this kind
of survey as well
um so you know the response rates are
generally low um
but
again as i'm saying uh
if you said a number you know and you've
ducked that but i said you know in terms
of it's 600 a thousand what becomes
acceptable uh
you know what what wasn't acceptable
democracy in terms of return or in terms
of representation of of of people voting
etc you know it's
it's never perfect but i think in terms
of um
in terms of what it's actually an
indication of i think it's acceptable
but that's that's my opinion
counselor constable
um
i've got a couple of issues on the
consultation um
my particular world
need none of the world councillors were
invited along i know other councillors
were invited along and they visited my
wall but none of my water councillors
were invited
the two areas i've got concerns about is
king george's playing fields which is a
playing field where half of it will be
lost
half of it is going to be kept as
football pitches but the bottom part
that was football pitches would be lost
to a meadow
and the malvern road site
is completely going over to wild meadow
and the complaints we get at the moment
is that the children can't play in that
area because they've lost the grass it's
only a very small area and i understand
the
issues with
getting machinery over to mow a small
area but they complain about that
already
the other
bit is that the wood councillors
understand their areas they know the
issues with their fields their playing
areas and i think working group will get
us not very far at all because it will
involve people not knowing your area and
i think consultations with the world
councillors would be far more beneficial
for each area as this progresses thank
you
if i may have called something that my
um
please feel free to to contact me anyway
i mean you know just don't don't feel
you have to wait on on sort of you know
um attention to to to to um comment on
these things i mean you know
um as world members you you please feel
free to represent your awards anytime
you wish so if there's concerns about
that that you didn't have an opportunity
to raise at the time then do please feel
free to contact me and my officers about
that and we'll gladly meet to discuss
that you know i said i think i go back
to
um it's not set in stone i want to
actually emphasize that if if um the
leader uh council wouldn't have said so
and and the portfolio holder said so
then then i i'm not going to go against
their word you know so to be clear
and so there is a flexibility there and
so i would encourage you know particular
members if they feel that uh there's
something that they want to address in
those plans that still has not been
successfully addressed and i said please
contact me i mean it's not it's as easy
as that really thank you
also
when we were out um
we did as as councillor craigslist said
did meet a number of residents
explain what we were doing
and i don't think any anybody made a
negative comment about it they all
understood they supported it and they
realized that this
for a lot of them was for the benefit of
the future generations they understood
that there is a limitation to what we as
a district as individuals can do but
they they all went on board i think we
must have kind of come across another
dozen yeah
yeah and and
we didn't get any negative comments now
subsequently things may happen and this
is what we're saying this is where the
flexibility will come in but the initial
reaction was very very positive on the
day
councillor drive
thank you chairman
um i support this initiative
um it's certainly a start it's going to
be flexible when we've got to start
somewhere in order to be carbon neutral
by 2030
there has been a public consultation
which may or may not have been have been
perfect but it supports a concept
i'd also like to echo the words of
councillor mrs gadsden in as much as i
was given a number of dates
to meet with adam aldridge and council
sparing
to
go through all the four sites within my
ward
there was no set agenda there and i gave
my views in a number of cases they were
flexible enough to accept my views
so i would support this
and i would like to see this come back
to perhaps this committee mr chairman in
12 months time just to review see how
things are going
but i support the initiative
council mrs mason
we must remember the mic
yeah i think the principle is not being
challenged what we're concerned about is
the methodology which seems to be in
different on different walls so it would
appear with different members having
different experiences
and
major concern is a simple one is that
the carbon neutral
aims seem to dominate over the other
uses of open space
so can i just ask two questions here of
the officer
do you know if you have got responses
from users of every site
and as the other question i'll ask them
both at the same time for ease the other
question i was advised uh the map for
clemenceville recreation centre which is
the one that's of course the most
controversy in my area
was that roughly a third of it was going
to be planted with trees
that's the case
where's the flexibility how do you
remove the tree
if i may um now
and i've both discussed with with
council experiment with regards to the
tree plant and tree planting is
something we want to bring in straight
away so you'd leave areas
as long grass but with the intention to
to plant trees
and again to see what responses from the
public
in terms of of
am i confident that we've got uh
representation from each site
no i did i i that was not the case of
the cert the the consultation has
established the principle
we recognize that each science has to be
um dealt with separately which is why we
said we're encouraging this flexibility
and while the maps will go up and
the um signs would have to say these
areas will be left for conservation and
we encourage response at that time to to
cater and to if you like um tailor the
sites at that time hence why we brought
the service in-house because we
recognized that we're going to need this
flexibility at the start of the process
thank you for the confirmation
council newport
thank you chairman for allowing me to
come back um
yeah sorry i did miss out um a question
and that was
i just wanted to know about the scope of
the parks for nature initiative in terms
of
where the council
looks to reduce open spaces on new
estates and replace them with artificial
pitches
um
how is that taken into consideration in
the scope
will
spaces on new estates be in parks for
nature's when the council adopt those
areas if they adopt them
or should i say green spaces
is that something that we'll look at in
the future or will those spaces be left
as
intended by maybe a
developer would intend
nicely manicured
and
and
just going back to one of my original
questions
will the saving from the grounds
maintenance be invested in the parts for
nature
scheme
thank you the
the
the first question i i'm going to be
honest in some i'm not quite sure
what you meant i apologize
is there a specific example you could
give i'm just saying you know the open
spaces say on the birds estate for
example
would that be included in our parks and
open spaces initiative
or parks for nature initiative or would
those open spaces just be open spaces
and just as the developer intended
would that
be included later on where we adopt if
we adopt those spaces good grief there's
a hard personal question
no because it is something that is being
looked at if well look look if um if
they're adopted then i think that's the
time to ask the question and i'll give
you an answer
i mean i mean and you know i mean in
theory yes you
you know the scope at the moment is that
it's the sites that we we can manage
have effects on it obviously
sites that are outside of our
uh our management we don't have that
effect on so you're saying if they if a
site was brought into our management
would be considering it um
in terms of how we deliver that site in
terms of uh improving it from a
biodiversity point of view then i
suspect you would then the answer would
be yes yeah
yeah it's only because obviously we know
that some of the spaces have been
reduced in size
and i was just thinking about the raw
earth estate where the open space has
been reduced and then would that be
given over to
you know
meadow grass or whatever
i think
it's just it's just i'm just wondering
from uh yeah i think moving i think
until we we have responsibility for
these areas
as as mark has already said
we we can't really comment on on
it won't be it's not our land
technically
we we can't then just go in and dictate
what we're going to do is not our area
to do to be responsible for if if we
get
given for whatever reason by default
well then i would suggest that it would
then come under the same consideration
as the rest of the district that's what
i wanted to know
money so the other question was it was
around the the
savings that that may occur from this
and what what they were used for i mean
so
that would be a decision for the uh
mtfs
to finalise so it'd be something
obviously that would come to full
council as to how the budgets are set so
i'm probably not in a position yet to
comment on how that money will be used
just because you know we we're in the
budget setting processes on salad
so i i can't answer this time okay thank
you
thank you
members um
i know that there are some outstanding
concerns with members from different
walls um but
there has been a positive response from
the portfolio holder and mr hoffman this
isn't set in start um
i would be in favor of establishing a
working group i understand the point
that comes that councilor constable made
which is that we would need to look at
this on the wall by wall bases
so i'm going to put a motion forward
it's not going to be in great detail
because i think one of the first
one of the first steps will be to
jointly agree
with the officers and other stakeholders
and ward members
what the terms of reference was it could
work in groups would be
and so i i would i would move from the
chair and to refer the decision back to
the executive
with a further action to establish a
member working group to work jointly
with officers and other stakeholders
portfolio holder
on proposals at each site
thank you chairman may i just make um a
proposal about one amendment to that
yeah could it be alongside the carbon
neutral working group as well as one of
those stakeholders you mentioned
okay so that
has been moved by myself seconded by
councillor wilkinson those in favor of
the motion
chat sorry excuse me sorry chairman if i
may can you just repeat the wording of
that
motion didn't quite catch it yeah okay
so it is to refer the decision back to
the executive
with the further action to establish a
member working group to work jointly
with officers and other stakeholders the
portfolio holder alongside the carbon
neutral working group
on
proposals
at each
site chairman i would suggest it's not a
referral of the decision because the
decision has been made but you're asking
the executive to set up a working group
so you're making a recommendation for
the executive to set up the working
group are you not
you're not referring the decision back
if
if that makes sense right so refer to
it's making a recommendation to the
executive
to and then um whatever the word he
wants to set up the working groups to
work alongside so
so the motion is to make a
recommendation to the executive
for an action to establish another
working group to work jointly with
officers
and other stakeholders the portfolio
holder alongside the carbon neutral
group
to work on proposals at each of the
sites can we change the decision
yes
the committee's um
agrees with the principal and
you just want the working groups to be
set up so you're asking the executive
yeah you're not changing the decision
thank you
close again
thank you
yes of course
uh he's five minutes
sufficient so we'll adjourn for five
minutes
okay welcome back members
we've now got item seven
which is the management of public open
spaces and this was
a working group established by this
committee and council mrs mason is going
to provide a verbal update on the work
of the working group
all right thank you mr chairman um the
question raised earlier about of sites
outside of uh
management leads very nicely actually
onto this item
to introduce this the management of
public open spaces working group
was set up due to concerns regarding the
use of private management companies for
the delivery of the maintenance of
public open spaces on new estates
and nationally expressed issues in this
regard
i think we're all aware of some of the
it's described as the next pip but i'm
not sure that it's quite that bad
it is within the determination of local
authorities to agree
and implement both funding and
management agreements for these spaces
either by condition or within section
106 agreements
whilst there are benefits when these
agreements work well
such as residents having control over
both the level of expenditure
and quality of upkeep
the demerits would appear to outweigh
the benefits
difficulty and conflict over management
levels
costly administration overheads
often managed by companies with little
local knowledge or connection to the
area
companies ceasing to exist
an unlimited charge on top of the normal
council tax banding
public open space is maintained at the
expense of private householders with no
control over access to name but a few
the working group initially looked at
both past and future provisions but felt
the scope was too wide to be effective
and referred the historic sites back to
this committee to organise an
independent group for this aspect on the
6th of july 21.
the investigations
undertaken by the working group included
personal research by the members
the sharing of knowledge
a report commissioned by officers from
burkitt's
detailed maps of the areas under
consideration existing ones
discussion and comparison of further
various options
the
option um
that the
consensus seemed to be
was the option one which was to go back
to the council
um the pros for this
with tried and tested option which is
well understood which there are
presidents for that can be examined
flexibility to tailor on a case-by-case
basis
via the planning process
the problem of unmaintained spaces is
avoided and benefits residents
and the fairness of treatment to all
residents regardless regarding payment
of maintenance of public open spaces
the downsides were the potentially
unaffordable costs
the rising costs of maintenance need to
be factored into the maintenance charges
to developers under the section 106
requires the parish or district to be
the provider of last resort
and cuts to funding might lead to the
district or parish undertaking a minimal
and unacceptable level of maintenance
so
very briefly and i'm trying to be brief
the conclusions of the working group was
the general consensus was that
maintenance of public open spaces should
be brought back under the councils
or
if appropriate the parishes control on a
case-by-case basis
with provision made under the section
106 agreements
and appropriate alterations to the
council's policy made
if needed
that this should now be dealt with by
the appropriate portfolio holder to
determine a way forward with officers
and to assist
it is suggested that the portfolio
holder considers the public report by
chelmsford council is being helpful here
i hope who have recently explored this
area and arrived at the same conclusion
and their report is publicly available
and i think very helpful
so the recommendation is that the
appropriate folio holder instigates an
alteration to the council's policy to
allow for public open spaces on new
developments to be maintained by either
the council
or parish council on a case-by-case
basis as would be done under any
conditions on planning
and that the fulfilling hold it
instigates a change to the section 106
policy as necessary to facilitate any
change in policy that's required
so
very brief
any questions
good
in that case mr chairman if there's no
questions
all right for clarity mr chairman i
think i did say but if i haven't made it
clear if it's in a planning application
on a section 106 it would be going
forward the historic
sites as i said were have been referred
back to this committee to look at
because there are some very serious um
issues on some of the historic sciences
has been mentioned earlier in this
meeting that the council is having to
deal with
some sites have worked well
some sites have worked
adequately and some sites are in a very
serious situation where management
companies have disappeared and residents
don't even seem to know that they're
responsible for the
open spaces that bequeath to them so
that's a different issue this is for
going forward for new planning
applications
where a developer proposes an open space
it would come under the council's
control
the council would therefore negotiate
with the developer for a cost to towards
that
should be is
could you just repeat that um excuse me
a microphone for missus
um
um
there's nothing we can do about
historical sites
um unfortunately
those
those are decided and
whatever process is in places in place
as councillor mrs mason says if the
developer offers
um
the council or the open space there is
opportunity for the council to negotiate
and um
when it comes under control and and any
sums or any requirements it it may need
to manage that site
but there's nothing we can do about
historical sites
they negotiate agreement so they could
inferiorly negotiate with the council to
take over because at the moment they're
paying a monthly fee
so that they could
adjust if you're if everyone's paying
one council attack yes and the
residents who
actually are the organization that's
done that doesn't decide they could
decide to cancel the contract they've
got with the service provider and then
it's a private entity isn't it
it's will be the council
deciding whether we would want to take
it on
not necessarily counselor garden not
necessary
i mean
it would be a
um
significant shift in policy uh
in in term and in terms of i guess
resource required so i think what's been
alluded to up until now it could be
adopted in a new local plan so you know
um it's not unusual for uh
sites to be taken on news sites where a
uh 106 agreement has been negotiated and
it feels like almost a dow return for
that land to be managed
and but in this situation where you're
you're retrospectively taking over yes
you're absolutely right if
if um
the uh
management committee invited the council
to come in and and
ladies and gentlemen to asking any other
company to do so um particularly for
saying can you please do it for free um
the the aspect of course will be just
where that resource comes from you know
correct me if i'm wrong with that that
was the the driving force of looking at
this
uh as a working group in the first place
wasn't it was trying to to address these
disparities
sorry mrs mason yeah
you indicated you still wouldn't speak
here
councilman smashing did you still want
to speak
you'd indicated
yeah you'd indicated
it's one of those nights
the um
the driving forces
the officer marcus has said
quite correctly behind this was the
inequality of treatment
between residents of new estates and
other residents because all residents
pay a council tax
banded on the
value of perceived value i would say
probably of their property
as
it is
um
we looked as i don't think the council
quite heard what i said i'll say it
slowly the working group initially
looked at both the past and future
provisions but felt the scope was too
wide
we referred the historic sites back to
this committee to organise an
independent group for this aspect on the
6th of july so this report
is looking to the future
the historic sites are complex
they're different everyone is different
the ownership of the land is usually
infested in
the properties
via various management companies and
it's confusing i grant you because
you have a management company that owns
the land on behalf of
the
residents and you have a management
company that manages the land on behalf
of the residents
each
of these sites
are slightly different legally but it's
complex but this report is purely about
going forward
not any historic sites and the reason
behind it the rationale is to prevent
future inequality
so if i can read the recommendation
again
that the appropriate portfolio holder
instigates an alteration to the
council's policy
to allow for public open spaces on new
developments to be maintained by either
the council or parish council on a
case-by-case basis
and that the portfolio holder instigates
a change to the section 106 as necessary
to facilitate changing policy um
excuse me mr jim i just want to ask a
question of the monitoring office i've
just realized that i believe i still i'm
technically on the deeds of
one of these properties but it wouldn't
affect this it's not just it's
disclosable interest is it because it's
a historic one
you need to declare an interest yes
sorry
you're you're sorry i think i'm named as
a trustee on a property on an existing
estate but it's not a new estate so that
would be okay wouldn't it
you would need to declare
non-billionaire interest in the interest
of transparency okay thank you i've
suddenly realized that i'm still on the
documentation thank you so i'll declare
non-pecuniary interest on that
um
and that the portfolio holder instigates
a change to section 106 as necessary to
facilitate the change in policy
council newport
i'd like to second that please
check the recommendations
i think
yeah i mean that's a good point i think
we
perhaps we could stay the
resolution for this evening and pick it
up at the next meeting when it will be
written down so the
council mrs mason will provide a written
report
um
we have
had it seconded so all those in favor of
the motion please indicate
all those against
that motion is lost
thank you chairman um as it has already
been requested perhaps if we could have
a written report with some detail for
the next review meeting and then i'm
sure um councillors will be better
equipped to be able to vote on
that item thank you
do i have um a second after that
proposal please actually a point of
order you can't have another vote on it
after six months now so it would be
timed out
and secondly
the monitoring officer has advised that
working groups don't have to provide
formal minutes formal notes
etc and i would not be
providing minutes for that but however i
will be giving a copy of my information
to the officer to put it into the
minutes thank you
thank you chairman
if that that is the case
but i do think that for new councillors
it was quite a difficult thing to be
asked to vote on thank you
moving on to item eight which is the key
decisions document
um
will be dealt with
yeah the proposal is to establish a
working members working group just to
deal with the history
that working group will be established
you know they are separate they are two
separate
problems as it were
yeah and so there were two there would
be two separate works
um
when that working group is established
to assist the council that um
the this was with if she in the minutes
this was referred back at the last
meeting so we're not discussing that
here at all it will come up in the work
plan um as a matter of personal advice
if it's the historic sites i believe
that you might be in a situation where
you have to declare a personal interest
the monetary officer will advise you
because it will affect it could affect
you
on the same people
in that case that that's fine but i
thought you
a committee decision there is a
six-month rule so the working group
informally uh made recommendation for a
decision for this committee to decide
um and
members had made that decision so there
is a six-month rule in place right
okay thank you thanks
okay thank you
so much which is the key decisions
document
um
as always i propose to just go through
uh item by item and if anyone has got
any observations or any comments uh
please indicate
so on page two of the key decisions
document
we've got the first one zero three
stroke 21 suspension of parking charges
on saturdays before christmas
the next
key decision zero four stroke two one is
the voluntary sector grant allocations
2022-2023
on page three the next key decision zero
five two one connect program investors a
business case and pipeline of projects
the connect program yeah
thank you mr chairman um with regard to
that decision that looking to bring
forward a paper on the customer portal
which is the access portal for customers
to use the website so one
login opportunity for residents to log
in put their inquiries in and get
response back and to monitor them
thank you mr stevenson
the next item is
decision zero stroke two one which is
waste transfer arrangements
the next item is zero nine two one which
is the ripper policy and ripper social
media guide
it's the uh regulatory
investment yeah
so it's the it's powers that um
yeah
so for example we may look at someone
perhaps who is committing benefit from
it it's the act that allows us to do
that
and then finally
key decision 10 stroke 2-1 is the
anti-social behavior policy
no one has indicated thank you
we come to the last item which is the
work plan
and just to give you an update of some
of the discussions that i've had
with some of the assistant directors
i've had a i've mentioned in the past
that i've
had a very productive meeting with
louisa moss
regarding the
upcoming
housing and
homelessness policy and
louisa is looking to produce a report in
the first quarter of next year and she
would very much welcome um
involvement from this committee so if
that is an area that you would be
interested i'll be writing out to
everyone but if you are particularly
interested in that please let me know
because you you can form part of the
group that looks at that
we've i've spoken to matt harwood white
about
the um disposals framework and again i
think i might have mentioned this at the
previous meeting and what this relates
to is disposal of council assets such as
um
changing room facilities and sports
pavilions that sort of thing
in my conversation with matt matt
explained that
this policy has been exist in existence
for a few years now and it it's probably
time that it was looked at to see how
it's worked historically and how we
could improve it going forwards
so
on the work plan itself if we um
if we look
the next
at the next meeting we'll be looking at
ripper
reviewing our annual policy
like that
okay so councillor wilkinson you've
indicated
yeah i think that was it
two questions and i know this is missing
from here is
an update on
um
as a is who would come to us and review
um an update as to
um because i i'm interested to know
where we are about
what amendments we've made what change
we've made with council where we're
going with that
that's something to come to us
the council would request the lga as
part of the ongoing improvement plan
and so that was sort of the council of
commission there'd be an action plan at
the back of that which the
administration um
would hold if it was something you'd
like to see sort of where the action's
gone that we can look to take that away
i can pick that up with the executive
so to assist that the lga come in and do
a second review so they just come in a
light touch review after normally 18
months or two years with the with the
pandemic obviously it's been slowed down
to normally come in and do that so i
could take that away and feed back to
the chair where we are with that and
when that's planned to happen then that
will give a review of where we are with
the actions that they put forward
previously it's now some of the work
we're doing is unless it's based wide
looking at recovery
we you can look at that we can it could
be something
to see
that we had a report brought to this
committee last year
by angela um
okay so you'd like to see an update on
that
council mrs mcpherson thank you very
much chair um i'd like to make a
recommendation to go on to the work plan
that we actually look at um
consultations our consultation process
and um
improvements that could be possibly made
to the communications
um
tying in a little bit with
councillor mr wilkinson's request around
the covered action plan
i would like to see
the emergency plans come back to this
group for the district and the progress
on those
with the caveat that the report before
missed certain details so if we go back
to the minutes that was going to come
back to this group as well
so giving them time to do that i would
see that
and
quite further down our
work plan agenda
okay thank you very much chair thank you
uh councillor mr shaw oh sorry cancer
sorry cancer are you coming back on i
was just gonna say exactly the same as
uh
my apologies chairman and mrs stevenson
and i uh i had to miss the july meeting
and i've just been told it was discussed
july 19th so cancel that request
i'm sorry
cancer mr shaw is that what you're going
to say
okay thank you
councillor mrs mason
december i think it was almost two years
ago i've lost track no december last
year we had on the work plan a review of
the constitution which was meant to be
completed before the start of the
municipal year um not only has that not
reported back but it's got lost
somewhere but it's got lost off the work
plan so perhaps you could advise
what's happening with that and if
anything
yes chairman all i can say is a working
process counselor mrs mason although the
um the overview and scrutiny piece is
the start of the whole constitution
going forward yeah
it ties in with the peer review as well
yeah thank you
councillor newport
thank you chair
and i wholeheartedly agree with
councilman mcpherson and they um put in
the
consultations on to review but one
question i do have the statement of
community involvement and that's out for
consultation at the moment is
does that only apply to planning or does
that
apply to does that involve consultations
generally as well
because i'm just thinking whether that
should be brought
chairman if i may i can answer that that
only applies to planning oh okay um
the the duty to consult um there are
certain um
uh statutory consultations not all
consultations are are guided under
statute so um
we can do a piece of work around
consultations and i believe
the assistant director louisa moss
it's within her directorate to look at
that policy and
um i'm sure she would have been happy to
work with his committee so would we
bring that the results of that
consultation into council
mcpherson's proposal
the results of the that consultation
that's a planning matter that was just
totally that's completely separate
thank you
and then one final item on the
um part of the work plan was that um
the
report that went to the executive about
a seller um was called in but it's not
form part of the
work plan here
but i've had discussions
with the
leader of the council
and he produces a regular report that i
gave an undertaking
to produce a regular report i don't want
to put you on the spot but i have sort
of pre-briefed you but councillor would
you be able to advise members on how you
are reporting
the work of the seller please
microphone
thank you chairman good evening members
um
on the full council meeting of the 20th
of october 2020
i undertook to
update members at least twice a year on
the
progress and information about asella
and that accompanied a pretty detailed
report but that was my that was my uh
comments
at the time
on the 11th of june
of this year uh a
press release went round uh which was
outlining the five
streams the growth streams that a seller
was proposing
and
then in
july 22nd of july we had the executive
meeting which uh proposed the formation
of a joint committee that rockford would
agree
to being one-seventh of the agreement
because there's five six other
authorities that make up a seller
and move to a joint committee just prior
to that
executive
there was a 15 slide presentation
available for all members
on the work of a seller
and that covered the
in more detailed detail the five work
streams
but of course the purpose of the main
purpose of the executive report
in
july
was to agree to a joint committee but it
also accompanied the growth prospectus
that was put forward to central
government so i think
if we look at
the communication of which i was highly
critical when i became leader chairman
there has been a considerable
improvement uh in the issue of press
releases and reports to council
and i would just finally finally say
that the
commitment to a further 2.2 million
pounds
announced last week for
full fibre success
rockford even got a mention in that
press release by referring to it being
run between perfectly on thames and
canoedon in the east
so i think chairman and thank you
members
there has been a considerable amount of
communication but that doesn't mean to
say that once the joint committee
is agreed there will be a
a governance requirement for a seller to
report at least once a year
to full council and provide a full
report
thank you chairman thank you
could i just ask you when will you
be producing your next report for full
council
i think the timing of that would be
following on from the joint committee
from the first meeting of the joint
committee um we're in various stages
because different councils have taken it
at different times tharak actually went
as early as march
and we took it in july i think brentwood
took it around that time as well uh
essex
may still be in the process i'm not
quite sure i believe ethics still have
to take it to um
to their governance through their
governance process
because
members may be aware that essex have
come back to the club uh they're very
keen on being part of a seller moving
forward
given the fact that we've now got much
better definition in terms of the work
streams and the products that it's
actually uh planning to deliver through
a joint committee which answers a number
of my concerns about
openness transparency publication of
agendas publication of minutes uh and
general communication
thank you chairman
any observations on the frequency of
council wilkinson
for you chair uh to the leader um
forgive me as this is going to show my
naivety here this is a genuine question
um it's interesting you say that essex
have come back to the club i and i may
have been told this as a joke when i
first was first elected but i thought
the history of a cellar was because
uh essex county council tends to look
favored more favorably upon the northern
districts to the southern districts and
we the ones that almost like the the
poor relation
and and i thought that's what the
history of a cellar was about to protect
the southern districts or have i got
that completely wrong which sort of
makes it quite strange why essex will be
part of the club there's some very
bright smiles going around the table at
the moment
there is some right smiles because if
you look at the makeup of south essex in
essex county council terms you have two
unitaries and that has effectively made
the governance
our voice in essex a little bit
lightweight in the south of the county
and yet
the economic wealth is generated don't
ask me for some figures off the top of
my head but the majority of the economic
growth and wealth is generated in south
essex
so you're absolutely right to highlight
that point and one of the reasons for
a seller is to
really
identify and
if you like communicate to central
government the opportunities especially
with the creation of freeport
the economic benefits
so a seller does
have a role to play to fly the flag of
the economic benefits but in fairness
since the change of administration in
essex in may
there is much greater
enthusiasm shall i say by the now leader
councillor kevin bentley
to want to be a much more integrated
force
within a seller to work with a seller
recognising the benefits i hope that
answers thank you very much
thank you chair
if i may ask the leader via you chair a
question or two
um
answer watson um
how will
um
or will you
as leader consult with our residents on
issues raised within a cellar
and
um you've just mentioned the thames
freeport
and i do have some reservations as to
our involvement in that given
our
transport links to the freeport as you
know
crossing that way is rather difficult
as people most people have to drive to
um tilbury et cetera
so
how
going forward
i guess the question is
um how
will rockford respond
to
um the growth of the freeport and how
will you deal with such issues
is that hopefully that's a fair question
to ask
uh
thank you chairman and and uh
councillor newport um i mean look you
are putting me i came as a spectator
tonight rather than as an integral part
of your meeting but
in terms of consultation
with residents
i think that would actually be a matter
for full council it would be a matter
for us to take a full paper to council
and actually decide
what we were going to consult on um
because there will be reports there
there's the opportunity for members of
the public to attend those meetings um i
would be interested outside of this
meeting deciding what exactly it is that
you would want to consult on bearing in
mind that a seller itself
has no actual powers
we have made it very very clear that
sovereignty
and
the governance of all authorities
remains with each individual authority
so you know it is simply a mechanism to
identify and highlight the way in which
growth may be generated in south essex
and there are five clear work streams
to demonstrate that so
on consultation
i'd be curious to know what it is you
think that
it would be worth consulting on um that
doesn't mean to say that rockford itself
uh couldn't launch some sort of
consultation
process but
you are
quite reasonably um asking these
questions but
i'll be honest with you i haven't sort
of thought that through in a huge amount
of depth because i think it depends on
how you view a seller
thank you
mr stevenson's
thank you okay thank you
um thank you chairman um just to add to
that i'm just trying to cancel water and
obviously the report that went to
executive in terms of reference and one
of the clear bits around sovereignty and
decision making so if there was a
decision around the freeport and
actually the freeport in on the thames
estuary bid actually takes into account
the whole of south essex and
i call it the ripple effect but rather
than just one single error so actually
the freeport bid for thorac and the
thames estuary and barca
is based on the whole of south essex a
lot of the other bids in the country are
based on smaller geographic areas if
there was some infrastructure
improvement for around that like the
highways so approving the a127 or some
of the other a13 then those sort of
consultation will be run by the
statutory authority over as the highway
authority or authoric and we would then
be involved in the consultation as a as
a consultant
as well and we could run across a huge
example of where consultation might come
in if there was an impact directly in
rockford obviously we would undertake a
consultation for that so if there was
some sort of development that helped
assist the freeport then obviously we'd
have direct consultation on that we'd
own that as